bonjour j'ai rendez-vous là-bas
normalement d'accord entrepreneur malgré
le handicap Laurent Lapierre 58 ans vit
à trrappe en juin 2017 suite à un
accident de moto c'est ingénieur
informatique devient paraplégique
constatant le manque d'accessibilité
pour les personnes à mobilité réduite il
décide de concevoir un système pour
améliorer les déplacements au sein des
entreprises le principe adapter un
dispositif motorisé sur un fauteuil
manuel sans installation compliqué alors
c'est super simple on se met devant le
handin on approche les roues avant on
met les roues avant dessus on appuie sur
un bouton et on part on peut aussi
l'équiper d'un panier pour faire ses
courses voilà c'est c'est c'est
modulaire mais surtout c'est très simple
pour lancer son projet Laurent s'est
fait accompagner du ski cube à Mont le
Bretonneux cet incubateur de start-up
lui a permis de lancer orizeo en
septembre 2022 avec ses trois associés
une aventure entrepreneuriale malgré son
invalidité clairement j'aurais pas créé
cette société si j'avais pas été en
fauteuil puce que je j'aurais même pas
imaginé le besoin en fait le handicap
est pas une barrière pour créer une
entreprise ça peut même être quelque
part une force parce que quand on a des
interlocuteurs qu'on dit qu'on est en
fauteuil ou et cetera ben ça crée une
relation qui est pas la même que si on
se parle de de de de valide à valide
centres commerciaux aéroport ougar voici
quelques-uns des potentiels futurs
clients de Rizo actuellement en phase de
conception et de fabrication le handinot
commencera à être expérimenté dans les
sociétés au printemps 2024 tout comme
Laurent 75000 personnes en situation de
handicap en France ont fait le choix de
l'entrepreneuriat